When I ask people in Hamilton, "What is culture?"
I get a lot of different answers.
But what is it really?
What is its value?
And why does it matter?
So, where to start?
I live in this city.
It has roads, clean water, electricity, police stations, hospitals, schools,...
...but every city has these.
What makes Hamilton different?
Well, this could be where culture comes in.
Let's see: festivals and events, a thriving art scene,...
...stories and customs, a sense of history,...
...cool architecture, creative talent, public art,...
...and even outdoor places like parks, farms and waterfalls.
These are all considered to be part of culture.
All of these things create activity and buzz,...
...a positive energy known as cultural vibrancy.
And this vibrancy helps to build community,..
...define neighborhoods,...
...and make the place we live in have a unique identity.
It also leads to attachment.
People that are attached to Hamilton want to live here.
They get involved, and they talk about it.
As the word spreads, people come, and businesses too.
This attracts more people and then more businesses.
Creative talent is drawn to Hamilton,...
...and is already one-third of the labor force and growing.
I guess you could say that culture is all the things...
...that make life in a place meaningful and interesting.
It's valuable because it can promote identity, creativity, tourism, jobs, and growth,...
...and it matters because it contributes to quality of life,...
...creating attraction and attachment,...
...revitalizing neighborhoods, transforming cities,...
...and making communities attractive, open, welcoming, and vibrant.
So, if you take away culture, then what do we have left?
Get culture.
Love your city.